[applaudissements]
mais
et je suis contre la violence contre déjà qui
coulant de l'écran de télévision sur notre
les gens contre le fait que les gens sont des gens avec nous
ne vaut rien l'avis du peuple rien
signifie pour nos autorités comme
s'avère que c'est, on nous dit que
elle nous
va attaquer l'ouest qu'est-ce que cela signifie
à l'intérieur nous avons du Maidan
d'où viens-je, eh bien, comment pourrais-je
une personne ordinaire jamais
la politique n'était pas intéressée, mais cette année
il a changé la vie de beaucoup de gens
démolit il y a eu des élections mais il n'y avait pas le choix
à cause de toutes les politiques
motifs politiques tous plantés
candidats pour le pic était là 1svetlana
Dera de Poméranie
femme au foyer rien là
décidons que les gens vous ont tous deviné
alors elle a gagné
[applaudissements]